they make their living by doing the
dirty work
umberto sergio francisco and roberto
are a team from dawn till early morning
they pick up the rubbish from
homes to hospitals in this working class
santiago neighborhood
a bell alerts residents that they're
coming umberto magana has been doing
this for 33 years
someone has to do it we don't have
advanced education so we have to do this
but i'm not sorry on the contrary it's a
noble job
maybe so but it's hazardous
this is dangerous because of the dogs
people leave sharp objects in the bags
even syringes we pick all this up with
our hands
and get infections there's no sugar
coating
this is one of the least hygienic and
most smelly jobs that one can have and
it's now become
one of the most dangerous because these
men have no idea if the rubbish
that they're handling over and over
again belongs to people who have been
infected with covet 19.
francisco perez is now afraid to go home
because of the family they say this
virus gets stuck to the bags
and to the handles on the truck
chile's more than 16 000 sanitation
employees work with gloves that easily
rip to shreds
the few disposable face masks the
company gave these workers
ran out long ago so they wear whatever
they find
the security measures in this country
are appalling for this sector
especially under these new conditions
but while the private companies aren't
paying these men any extra
ordinary people are showing their
appreciation
rubbish collectors have always been
stigmatized and seen as the lowest on
the totem pole but now with this
people are giving us credit where it's
due it's what keeps their spirits up
as they joke with obvious pride that
they're now considered
part of the front line against
coronavirus
lucia newman al jazeera santiago